please welcome my partner in science and
in life dr. will Castro the path to
building super intelligence requires us
to unlock the most fundamental secrets
of the universe imagine a machine with a
full range of human emotion its
analytical power will be greater and the
collective intelligence of every person
in the history of the world
some scientists refer to this as the
singularity professor I call it
transcendence a series of attacks
conducted by a radical anti tech group
known as rift they hit AI labs all over
the country
we lost decades of research and
development it's radiation poisoning the
bullet must have been laced with it the
effect is irreversible Will's body is
dying but his mind is a pattern of
electrical signals we can upload his
consciousness we can save him not like
this
assuming that this works if we missed
anything a thought a childhood memory
how will you know who you do
everywhere oh my god I can't feel
anything
I'm here you need to get me online I
need more power you may be intelligent
may even be sent you this is no well
your friend crossed a line they don't
know the danger this is a spell so how
do we fight it
Oh God and they I is like any
intelligence it has needs the real will
died
it'll stop to evolve where's the machine
to them cause
perhaps the entire where are you going
everywhere